[Music]
in bright future use so many my cheese
Lord oh Lord
wait no cheese she's my soul
she's Santa's Airways CEO signed a
cooperation agreement with the
ten-year-old Qantas Qantas it doesn't
have a you so that's why I read it like
that
the Australian airlines sign a
cooperation agreement with the
ten-year-old okay
to do what why does that mean they have
to cooperate to stay quiet I'll be
travelling alone I travel alone did I
get it see how rude like how horrible
our world is that we immediately think
of like negative Wow is it positive one
oh well the world is negative I know
that's what I'm saying that's what I was
pointing out like that sucks look at the
world we live in right now something
like that then I got sense for a pretty
long time it's actually a little bit
better now than it was back then yeah
we're making progress very slowly so
Qantas has announced a partnership with
this this airline called Oceana Express
and this happened after a meeting with
Qantas CEO and Oceania Express CEO who's
a 10 year old the founder and CEO he's
the founder and CEO of an airline at ten
years old yeah is it family like owned
or is it like a fake airline it's like a
fake Oh little kid is like very
ambitious and he's just in love with the
aviation industry and so he wrote this
letter to the CEO asking him please take
me seriously and he said I have already
started some stuff like what types of
planes I'll need flight numbers catering
and more he said that he has already
appointed a chief financial officer the
head of IT even the old buzz words at 10
maintenance a head of onboard services
and a head of legal as well as his
friend wolf as vice CEO this will smart
as [ __ ] yeah I do I don't know how that
I'm like full-on running a business
right now he met with the CEO of Qantas
and he said that we want to capture all
that enthusiasm and formalize a
connection between Australia's oldest
and newest Airlines today we signed a
more more more more and dumb memorandum
right yeah that word Memorandum of
Understanding for our Airlines to
cooperate from - 2026 once alex has
completed high school it might be pushed
out of it if you chooses to go to
university which I hope he does is what
the CEO said so they're kind of doing it
like a cute thing like oh here it is if
your turn 18 and you still want to do
this we'll do it but if not then we're
good you can get back out of it pretty
much I give they're just it's a cute
story how he's trying to like inspire a
future airline CEO so that's really cute
I'm so amazed that the words that he
knows there's only 10 years old oh my
god how cute he's such a cute little
ten-year-old no look at how he said
please take me seriously that's me as
[ __ ] doing business
please seriously with that same
penmanship and then this is a meeting
great PR mph at Qantas and they created
this dough like mock-up of Oceania
Express on the Dreamliner he named it
right Danis tight so then this sort of
sparked a this program thing that now
they're doing at font is where they want
to invite children aged 7 to 12 to apply
to be part of this behind-the-scenes
visit where they can meet a bee-like
engineers pilots
and head office staff and then they
could share their thoughts on how
customer service can be improved and
that this program will be available or
like it will be starting during the
school holidays later this year so yeah
they want to inspire young aviators it's
really cool she's gonna be a bunch of
kids I don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] telling
them stupid ass things I wish there was
a bubble gum dispenser and
we have to apply they want them to to
fill out this form and write in 50 words
or less why they would like to spend the
day at quantis and the program is called
the Qantas future high flyers program I
do not trying to set an example from
after this kid but he actually like
dedicated a lot of his time energy and
like knowledge you know to like you
didn't tell this kid is actually
passionate about this he's not just like
I want to take a field trip there you
know yeah I would be the other kid I
just want to take a field trip I don't
want to he already know got a CFO is
that ten that's crazy yeah well he knows
he even needs legal and maintenance
doesn't clean itself he told this friend
like okay you're gonna be my VP so we're
gonna go here and present this yeah but
kid like that you have really cool
parents that's all I was gonna say what
his parents do yeah that like already
shown the ropes cuz um I forgot where we
were I think we were in Yosemite or
something and then there was a stand the
Sun and the Sun was probably no more
than like 9 or 10 and then he was
teaching like we were just walking so in
passing I hear him going well well
what's your elevator pitch do you know
what that is and I was like ha that's
what could tie it is really teach him
about elevator pitches and [ __ ] what's
an elevator pitch so if you're giving
anyone an idea like you try to summarize
your entire idea within the time it
takes from going one floor to the next
floor Wow
so that's like an concise quick and you
just give it to them yeah whether it's a
movie idea business idea like you wanna
yeah someone's attention within like 10
seconds yeah you don't want to sit there
and give it a go okay yeah some of the
email then oh wow so you would say
something like oh I'm a Latina power
lifter that you know came here for
Mexico with nothing and it's like and
now I want to do this and they're like
oh that's a movie boom or something
whatever you did that you're trying to
do damn elevator pitch the kid already
knows it at nine ya know so yeah those
are the same kids that get beat up at
school the other kids around this the
nine-year-old okay they're probably
going well actually my dad said that
I've all of that that's yeah they all go
to the right school yeah yeah I got one
smart kid in the regular school in this
game yeah I think that that's rare but
which one smart cute at a regular school
yeah kazoo be like not to be super smart
but to have that kind of knowledge where
your parents are like look this is my
business it's my CFO like
you know and I mean like if your parents
are talking to you like that means they
have time to talk to you like that if
they have time that means they have
money to afford the time you know so
most likely or not they're going to get
schools all right I'd like to think I
think so too I was gonna say do we know
what the parents do mm-hmm I don't know
but I'm really curious to this was in
Australia yeah maybe
is it the economy really good on
Australia pretty good jobs not here but
he would know all the answers top ten oh
it's top ten are we top ten no no I
think oh we're top ten okay got it
no no no no well no because I see I
think like okay there's a lot of rich
people here but then there's a lot of
not rich California California was a
country and it's removed from the u.s.
California is top ten yeah that's how
crazy California like California like
holds the u.s. on its back yeah we do I
think we have well I mean we do
everybody's pretty okay here you know at
least from what I can see you know like
even our ugly parts are still pretty
well off here like in El Hijo California
I think LA because that's what I know
Southern California you know compared to
like other places that are mentoring the
world you know but that's why I asked if
it's like how is the economy over there
cuz maybe his parents are like super
well off you know maybe yeah I'm
thinking from my future kid I'm bored to
letter so I could get the future to like
hey hey Tommy can you write it write a
letter to Nike and he then I'm like I'm
not trying to get those new J's ever
coming out right what does that say
about me as a parent I was like hey
write this letter be like please take me
seriously Nike you want a dumb kid or a
smart kid a smart kid get that's gonna
challenge the [ __ ] out of me yeah which
he already does already why would you
want your kid to be stupid easier does
we gonna be stupid together
go get about hey dad like killing it let
me let me correct you first [ __ ] the
[ __ ] up alright you can correct your mom
you don't correct me on daddy knows
everything even as a dad like you and me
if you have a super smart kid like you
can still get away with being like eight
like I'm the one that's in charge you
know yeah that's what this is for I just
put on there like do you like oxygen or
not maybe I should just develop their
brain but not their physical attributes
oh I just want to be super just weak or
maybe really really fat but it's [ __ ]
smartest [ __ ] no cuz I'm those are like
the super like snobby guys that are like
whoa love of love look I'm just super
smart you know what I mean like just
chill like a cool cool guy that's it
that's all you need
am I gonna be dumbest [ __ ] there's some
of this kids they just run around
chasing butterflies oh that's pretty
cute too yeah you know what Tiger Chase
is right now my dad told me so Tiger you
can't tell the difference between
butterflies and bees oh no he's been
chasing bees around stuff my dad has to
stop him all the time that's Titan did
well he didn't know the consequence of
one and a half one and a half [ __ ]
huge dude I know I was talking to my
cousin yesterday for an hour who I
haven't talked to in years don't over
Florida no this is the one in when we
saw last year on everybody I don't know
what because female yours are like I
have a few and guess okay that just
means like weeks okay so for all of you
out there that don't know what female
years are ours consist of 365 days
whatever years that's wrong oh well I'm
talking about my guy cousin so he um
he's been studying right now he's
working on his PhD and his like ultimate
goal is to become an astronaut oh that
one that one holiday he lives in Arizona
he's like 30 well you guys give me I
don't know there's some reason my
eyeline does message it to you but um
yeah so anyway I was talking to him what
do you know he interned at NASA and I
was talking to him about how Isaac is
like so about wanting to be an astronaut
right now he he like loves everything
about it and it was so sweet of him cuz
he was like oh yeah well when I was
interning at NASA they had this
mentorship program where you get to like
mentor this little kid and he said that
there was this kid that he meant heard
that he was
ten years old and they would do science
projects together through through Skype
because this kid was like in Tennessee
or something and then he offered he's
like yeah you know Isaac ever wants to
talk in like we can do science project
together suddenly he can actually get a
leg up on going in that path cuz for him
he didn't realize he wanted to be an
astronaut until he was like I don't like
older like 25 maybe and then that's when
he started working on was that being too
that like too late to start hold our
astronauts they're older but you have
had to like accomplish oh [ __ ] like PhD
is the start Wow yeah so a lot of them
are like former Navy SEALs or like
high-level military that get either MD
or PhD and then you're a possible
candidate so you got to be like the
cream of the crop of the human race and
then also he was telling me like all the
requirements that there's like different
avenues you can take to become an
astronaut and he was saying like yeah
one of the things because the US doesn't
launch anymore like right now we're
using Russia to get to the International
Space Station he's like astronauts need
to know Russian cuz they're gonna be
spending like two years out there to
Train so he's learning a Russian right
now he was telling me like yeah just
download duolingo for Isaac to start
learning Russian I mean we don't know by
the time he's older but he's trying to
be astronaut your cousin himself yeah
see what that oh did we do an article on
that poll yeah but I felt weird thing he
was my cousin so I didn't like say that
but that's that's my cousin guy
good-looking smart [ __ ] it was
something about a GoFundMe or some [ __ ]
like that him trying be an astronaut no
it was about him his struggles through
and then also I didn't mention he was my
cousin cuz I felt like a shitty family
member after reading a lot after reading
the article and seeing how he had to
live in his car eat potatoes for like
months and [ __ ] you didn't give him a
single dollar I didn't know that about
you Andy cuz for me I don't give a [ __ ]
if they're of my family if they're not
tight they're not really my family true
my dave is probably closer to me than
half my family cuz all [ __ ] losers I
agree to I want to let Dave asleep in a
car I think maybe like what should that
car
I have like a handful of family members
that I really like I'm close to and care
about and even though I don't talk to
him on the daily he's one of those
people Oh Dan you [ __ ] up there you're
a piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah that kind of
shows his I would say like his integrity
as a human being is that he doesn't want
to burn other people from his before his
own issues which takes a lot because I
know a lot of family members that are
doing perfectly funny they still want to
suck you dry you really have more money
than me and they're like goddess I need
some money here and there I'm like [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you talking about you piece
of [ __ ]
good on him busy watch load he's
floating on the moon now he doesn't grow
he's working his PhD yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]